les petits petons les petits potins les
stars qui répondent à leurs lecteurs
cette semaine le comédien guillaume
canet qu'on adore a répondu assez
sèchement à l'un de ses détracteurs sur
les réseaux sociaux
c'est parti d'une photo qui les veut
diffuser sur 1,5 compte instagram sur un
sur un tracteur un peu en mode de
paysans dont il n'est pas le premier à
répondre à ces auteurs qui les prennent
à partie parfois très violemment alors
ont-ils pourtant raison de le faire on
va en parler juste après ce magnéto
regarder donné la possibilité à des
tarer à des abrutis de s'exprimer chez
moi sur mon compte
c'est complètement idiot se faire
insulter sur twitter facebook ou
instagram par des gens qui envoient des
messages de haine et que l'on appelle
des haters les personnalités en ont
marre voilà par exemple les horreurs que
marlène schiappa reçoit par milliers
chaque jour face à ce cyber harcèlement
certaines stars ont choisi de répondre
comme guillaume canet taclé par
plusieurs followers après avoir posté
cette photo en mode agriculteurs
moustachu pour son prochain rôle
épinglé il répond donc au fait qu à
toutes les conversations tournent à
booster je porte la moustache d'abord
parce que le personnage portait une
moustache ceux qui voient là ne pas se
laisser faire c'est aussi le choix qu'a
fait mme illi bobby brown 14 ans 18
millions d'abonnés sur instagram
découverte dans la série strangers
things elle est très critiquée pour son
côté femme avant l'heure elle pourrait
ignorer la critique mais au contraire
elle assume
si je choisis de posté cette photo est
que vous ne l'aimez pas continuer à se
creuser
parmi les plus harcelé les stars de télé
comme anne-sophie lapix qui dit s'en
prendre plein la gueule ou laurence
boccolini mais aussi des champions de la
discrétion comme christophe willem 200
messages d'insultés par jour
dans le viseur surtout la communauté gay
cette photo publiée par marina foïs a
suscité une avalanche d'insultés
homophobes et postes effectivement
bloqué quelques heures plus tard par les
modérateurs
du coup certaines stars ont fait un
choix radical s'enfuir des réseaux
sociaux
voici ceux qui les ont quittés récemment
[Musique]
on
non
finalement la meilleure solution ne
viendrait-elle pas de george clooney qui
affirme que jamais il ne rejoindra
facebook alors les stars ont elles
raison de répondre aux acheteurs très
drôle
quelles raisons de répondre et r c'est
vrai que si on est ce qu'on les met en
avant est ce qu'au contraire il faut les
calmer un peu juste avant de vous donner
la parole il ya justement d exemple un
peu marrant il ya deux manières de
répondre il ya l'école un peu académie
française un peu drôle genre car ni
n'est acquis on disait je veux te voir
dans un film porno en action avec ta
[ __ ] et y répond merci de votre intérêt
de ce joli projet à voir avec mon avion
bien à vous ou sinon il ya l'école un
peu plus voilà tf1 jean pierre pernaut
pernaut n'a pas fait son traditionnel
reportage sur les soldes et répond va te
faire [ __ ]
voilà où les colts et pmp bon à l'école
la plus chic mais on adore télévie 2010
voilà qui ont dit à part potiche tu sert
à quoi elle répond et toi avec ta
tronche de cake voilà les manières de
répondre mais est-ce qu'il faut répondre
oui ou non au et hers
il ya pas beaucoup de moyens oui mathieu
alterman bah oui mais c'est quoi ce
qu'il faut leur répondre il faut
répondre à condition que ce soit drôle
parce que c'est des voix la wii venir le
problème c'est guillaume canet sa
réponse
tout ça parce que quelqu'un critiqué ces
photos qui effectivement quand on
regarde la photo et une envie un peu
d'envoyer une vanne parce qu'elle est un
peu très sérieuse tout ça donc je pense
que la réponse de lyon
quelle est pour le coup c'est voilà donc
un peu d'humour a manqué un peu de ski
mais il manquait pas d'humour je
conseille à tout le monde d'aller voir
le compte twitter de julien doré c'est à
mourir de rire au nez c'est très drôle
répond merveilleusement bien aux gens
qui dit j'en ai marre dans la voiture
avec mon père on écoute tout le temps
tout le temps ils répondent pas vous
n'avez qu'à voyager dans le coffre
enfin des trucs traitera dans l'avenir
oui alors et nous alors non pourquoi non
madame myriam quels sont les réseaux
sociaux tout le monde le sait c'est un
défouloir donc c'est rentrer dans un jeu
s'est donné en fait la parole à des gens
le fait de la science infuse réactiver
le truc en plus souvent comme le disait
mathieu s'est fait sans humour là pour
le coup c'est hyper vaches parce que
effectivement il fait pas rêver à lui à
elle n'a pas insulté
elle a juste commenté si tu veux pas
qu'on commande theft auto
effectivement ne crée pas de compte et
ne vient pas faire ta promo de sucer je
dois parler en plus ce qui est horrible
c'est que souvent si le people répond
c'est lui qui se fait taper dessus qui
ont dit oh la la il parle très mal à ses
fans dont
avant sert à rien juste avant parce que
magali on oui capitaine parler d'humour
et d'allemand c'est vrai mais c'est
tellement agressive ils se prennent
tellement des insultes je pense qu'à la
longue on en a ras-le-bol et que tu
balances mélange gigean la télé chasse
c'est toi qui dis ouais mais ça va pas
être évident la seule chose moi qui
m'étonne c'est que ces réseaux sociaux
il soit il ce soit en zone de finition
clients peuvent être puis oui ça ne nous
reconnaît voilà donc et c'est bien là
tout dit et j'aurais dit c'est con parce
que peuvent leur répondre c'est faux
parce que vous pouvez faire des mises en
demeure et twitter non machette saxe
saxe est arrivé pas pour moi mais pour
le gras on peut faire des maisons de
manger mieux récents et mise en demeure
twitter enlève la enlève les postes et
les gens sont voilà soit interdit de
venir sur le compte et cetera donc vous
pouvez l'imaginer condamné comme tu peux
l'être aussi à l'antenne je lui parlais
la twitter et ensuite tu peux toi faire
une mise en demeure avec un petit et
c'est alors magali alors pourquoi tu
répondes valeur est très dur ne pas
répondre c'est vrai mais en soit on leur
donne de la visibilité c'est à dire que
quintin qui vous insulte qui va pas être
vu à part par nous parce qu'on est
notifiée mais par contre si on lui
répond mais du coup on va mettre son
tweet en avant absolue moment de le voir
et ça va créer encore être encore pire
en fait là c'est vrai ça qu'il faut pas
si davin follower qui vous écrit que
vous vous répondez à vos deux millions
base d'un contrat de 2 millions de qui
ont vu son insulte ça c'est vrai qu'il
faut écarter chante un trait sur ta
fiche organes fini
[Applaudissements]
daniel moreau qui à fond sur les réseaux
c'est beaucoup a ajouté sur la radio a
certainement un avis justement j'ai
juste une phrase la bave du crapaud
n'atteint pas la blanche colombe donc
moi je pense qu'il faut répondre par le
mépris
non j'ai appris quelque chose merci
magali parce que j'y comprends rien fait
quand on met des trucs sais pas qui peut
lire keane d'accord pour lui mais je
veux juste me fait pas rêver qui me fait
pas rêver c'est pas guillaume canet sur
son tracteur c'est le fait qu' on puisse
comme ça à voir instantanément une
réponse les réseaux sociaux avec les
stars ça fait plus rêver
moi vous rendez compte quand je voulais
une photos d'annie cordy pardon je vais
envoyer lettre
j'attendais qu'elle me réponde ça promet
une semaine ou deux et ça me faisait
rêver
j'étais content d'aller là bas voilà
c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est vrai et
annie cordy donc pendant une semaine
vous rêviez pour vous les aimez autant
grâce à victor dit ah bah j'en ai alors
là j'en ai une collection plusieurs
journaux à la collection de tous les
autographes alors que c'est ma fait
l'amour merci maman annie cordy alors
passé un petit jeune monsieur ben ça
c'est guy lux il est là
quand même source